so I wanted to touch on two things
before we finish up so firstly I wanted
to ask what the current status of the
investigation is the current stage of
the investigation is that every year for
the last couple of years the Met has
asked for a small charge of money a
hundred and fifty thousand pounds to
cover you know six months of work or
three months of work and they have
scaled back their team from about 30
officers to only three or four they have
said repeatedly that they are pursuing a
line of inquiry that they want to finish
before they conclude their investigation
they they have a line of inquiry that
they think important enough to continue
to want to pursue the money always seems
to run out in March and in September and
they have just requested funding for a
full year now that's interesting it's
interesting to us and and this is it can
only be conjecture one would imagine
they wouldn't be doing that unless they
thought a that it was completed in that
amount of time or that they had
something that they thought was
important enough but perhaps a little
bit more complex than they originally
have forecast it would be that they
really needed to work on for that time
so so one wonders the continue the
investigation is continuing it remains
an open investigation in Portugal as
well but as of this moment we're in a
rather in a bit of a news vacuum how
about how love the the McCanns private
investigation is that obviously they
will still be doing things themselves
but why important and it can only be an
impression we have not been involved
with the McCanns personally
person-to-person for some time now the
kind of years but we we we we had the
impression that even then as soon as
Scotland Yard took over the case in
England
and then the the Portuguese who had
shelved the case up to them got back in
to the investigation themselves liaison
amicably at that point with Scotland
Yard that the McCanns who had previously
used private investigators to dig all
over the all over Europe and further and
beyond that they ceased and left it to
the police which was only right you
can't have cops and private detectives
all going at things hammer and tongs at
the same time my impression is that they
are waiting being briefed by Scotland
Yard when it is relevant to brief them
and trying to get on with their lives a
very difficult task because they are
still pursued venomously by the by
internet trolls
so this social are still threatening
spreading poison about the supposed
involvement in the death of their own
daughters we just don't think we've had
a moment to stress it and if we are soon
to complete this conversation we should
we would like to stress that the fact
that in all the work we've done on this
case
we never found an iota of an indication
that the McCanns had in any way being
guilty involved in their daughter's
disappearance
[Music]
you